hey guys dr. Berg here I wanted to answer a
question that keeps coming up will vegetable
carbohydrates stop ketosis okay so it is true that
vegetables are carbohydrates but the question is
do they turn into sugar fast or slow there's a
thing called the glycemic index and that is the
rate or which speed at which something actually
affects your blood sugars I guarantee a salad or
maybe like a spinach salad with celery when you
eat that it is not going to spike your insulin
okay so some people that start including more
vegetables let's say they're doing the Atkins
diet it's really high protein and fat and
yes the absence of carbohydrates do induce
fat burning but if you have no vegetable types
of carbohydrates what's going to happen you're
going to get a lot of waste in your body and
it's stuff called ketoacidosis or your body's
pH starts going higher and higher and higher
there's nothing to flesh that out so I want to
read to you guidance physiology what it says
in page 927 okay the effect of insulin lack
on causing a fatty liver calling causing the the
lack of insulin right when you keep insulin very
low since it costs a great increase in the amount
of store triglyceride in the liver leading to a
very fatty liver so in other words you got to
be careful doing ketosis because all this fat
that's being mobilized from your fat stores from
your stomach it has to go through the liver and
go through your bloodstream if you don't consume
the vegetable you're going to end up with a fatty
liver okay and that's defeats our whole purpose
and sometimes when people do this they all check
their blood in their cholesterol goes really
really high because they're not eating the
vegetables to counteract that now some people are
eating the wrong type of vegetables they're doing
corn okay corn is not a vegetable in my viewpoint
or they're doing a lot of cruciferous but they're
sensitive to it they're not digesting that so
they bloat the bloating will stop the weight
loss okay so just switch up your vegetables
do something like a fowl or something like
that but the vegetable cleans encounter acts a
lot of the fat burning that takes place and it
prevents the fat from accumulating in your liver
the other thing is that if you don't want to do
the vegetables then where are you getting your
potassium from from the meat from the fat there's
there's no potassium in there hardly any at all
so you need I mean a tremendous amount so were
you getting your magnesium where are you getting
all your vitamins and minerals that's where you
get them from the vegetable family okay so don't
worry about vegetables when you're doing ketosis
I think it's essential and I'm actually I put a
twist on this it's like my version of ketosis you
go ahead and do that and you'll actually end up
with a healthy body alright thanks for watching